Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
October 7th,
2013 October.
We're all the way into the fall.
Here it is officially October.
It's the month of pink.
Yes it is.
Are you aware that cancer is ensouled bodies,
boobs?
Hey,
I actually think that they weren't wearing,
um,
the,
the pink stuff as much.
I didn't think there was or maybe I'm just used to it.
Is that what it is?
I have no idea.
I had no fucking idea.
All I know is I watched some football yesterday and,
um,
first of all,
who's kidding?
Who?
Who is kitten?
I'll tell you.
Who's kidding,
who?
I'm kidding myself when I say this.
Next thing,
let's go red sox.
Here we go.
Team that I haven't watched all fucking year.
Boom,
boom.
I've watched to red sox games this whole year.
Game One and game two of the playoffs.
Hey,
like what's his face says in the warriors?
I've been busy.
All right.
I was too fucking busy to watch him added.
That isn't the truth.
The truth of the matter is,
uh,
one of my favorite players tested positive for some substance in 2010.
And at that point I was like,
you know what,
I'm going to give baseball fucking rest here.
Okay.
I'm sick of feeling like a fucking eight year old,
not even an eight year old,
a four year old who's,
who's,
you know,
and then they won the championship and they lived happily ever after.
And I go to bed with my little broken smile cause might be young,
two faces is starting to fall out and I get a quarter under my pillow and I
believe that everybody did it in an honest fuck away.
And then three,
four years later,
ESPN comes out with you.
Yet another guy,
another fresh faced white dude,
you know,
with little habit dash on or maybe a former player,
maybe a former player comes on and then they fucking let me know that everything
that I thought was,
wasn't everything that he thought his isn't add a that I'm just a dump freckled
cunt.
And I just,
I got sick of it.
So,
so I haven't been watching.
I mean,
I,
I kind of,
you know,
it was watching as they dismantled Terry left town,
Theo Epstein,
he's,
he's over out there in Chicago and I watched the gradual,
the whole thing disintegrate.
But,
um,
I do,
you know what's funny,
I was actually texting another buddy of mine,
like,
oh,
hey,
I agree you've been watching the red sox at all?
And he goes,
yeah,
I've been watching them and I open,
openly admitted.
I was like,
dude,
I'm,
I'm beyond fucking bandwagon this year.
And he laughed and he goes,
so am I where we both live out fucking on the west coast now?
And we were watching the game and he was literally saying like,
he,
he was thinking shit like,
Hey,
you know that Asian guy,
we got really good.
Neither one of us do is name our relief pitcher who,
I can't even say his lights out because I've watched 18 innings.
Um,
some of it with the sound down and I don't even know the name of our clothes.
I just know that he's Asian and he's,
he's been killing it.
So,
um,
oh my God,
you're going to see it.
If the Red Sox win the world series and I go out and get the hat,
cause you know you got to go out and get the hat.
All right.
Put your arms around other fans.
Yeah.
Well la go down.
You Act like you've been there.
Well I'm here to admit,
right.
You know what I'm doing right now.
I'm doing that thing when somebody fucks up in a game and afterwards when the
report has come to the locker room,
rather than let the reporters say how bad you sucked,
you just own up to it.
Oh you're going to talk to her.
I take full responsibility or there's the,
or let my teammates down.
I let down my mom,
my high school coaches,
you know,
everybody hates me.
I'm going to let you know I hate myself even more than you hate me.
Okay?
I suck.
Look at me and pointing right in my face.
I shuck.
Okay,
so you don't need to write it.
That's what I'm doing before you guys call me out for being Oh,
Billy bandwagon.
I'm like,
you know,
I am all right.
Purlins.
I'm onboard from day one,
although I haven't watched a second of it yet,
but I take the fucking games over there.
Um,
I was on the road.
Alright.
Even busy is fucking busy.
I went this week and Went El Paso to San Jose,
then it went up to Seattle.
Um,
and then I went down to Phoenix,
Arizona,
another great fucking week.
But if it was airport,
airport,
is that what it was?
No,
I drove to El Paso.
That was a good time.
You know,
the old me would've gone in a straight shot.
12 hours.
I got this.
I'll leave at 10 in the fucking morning and get there at 10 at night.
Have myself a fucking case at dia and I would just gone to bed.
But,
uh,
I'm fucking old now.
I got right around Tucson and I was like,
Oh,
I'm trierd
my ass hurts.
And um,
I got to get fucking hotel and I get to tell you,
it was great.
It was great.
I drove for like eight hours.
That's what I did.
I drove for eight hours and um,
and then the next day I woke up and I drove basically from Tucson to El Paso and
it was fucking,
it was awesome,
man.
Going through the bad lands of,
uh,
New Mexico with is just fucking nothing out there.
You know,
it's funny,
somebody sent me on Twitter was saying,
you know,
I hope bill doesn't have a beautiful drive out to El Paso so I don't have to
hear about it.
And that fucking made me laugh.
So God hard just because of what is behind that.
Like how miserable was your fucking childhood that you don't want to hear
somebody say that they had a great time and that this is a beautiful country.
Like you'd much rather have me go out there and be like,
just fucking nothing out there.
You know,
a bunch of fucking
fucking Indian reservations.
You know,
we should just kill the rest of them.
Right.
And put up a fucking sports bra,
you know,
fucking moron.
That's,
but you know what?
But he's younger.
I think it was John Younger,
judging by his Avatar.
You liked that?
I picked up that little word of Technology Avatar C I l e o fucking week ago.
I just thought it was a movie.
We're shit floated around you and there was these blue people was like,
it was smurf porn,
right?
If you're straight like it was SMURF porn.
That's what that fucking movie was.
Smart porn combined with the way that guy drew those pictures on good times when
they pretended Jimmy Walker painted him.
Remember that they'd have a dude dunking a basketball and his arm would be like
extra long.
It's combinded both of those schools
I feel,
you know,
and at the end of the day,
I don't remember a fucking second of that movie.
I just remember somebody had a,
I just remember that the,
didn't everybody have like hair?
Like every quarterback in the NFL except it was blue.
Okay.
I Dunno how fucking know
they had the same body types of that dude.
It goes right from high school into the NBA.
You know,
not quite a boy and not quite a man body.
And you fucking six,
10.
Yeah.
Am I thinking of the right fucking well anyways,
judge her by this kid's Avatar.
He was,
uh,
he was,
you know,
young.
He was in his twenties.
So your 20s is all about taking your childhood out on everyone that you'll run
into.
You're not,
you don't realize that you're doing it.
At least this is how my life went.
Now granted,
if you had,
if you had a wonderful childhood,
if there was no conflict,
I mean,
what is a wonderful childhood?
What it was a one,
it was,
whew.
Um,
whatever.
If you had one where people,
um,
there's no way that there's no way to not fuck up your kid.
What it really is,
is you're trying to fuck it up the least,
the least amount that you can,
you're trying to send your kid out into the world with the least amount of
fucking issues.
So,
okay.
I Dunno,
I guess that they could be happy.
And then also that you don't have to be sitting in the back of a courtroom and
complete denial that,
yeah,
you know,
your kid fucked a dog.
No,
I just think it's going to come.
We'll see it.
Present the evidence.
I think,
you know,
yes,
there was dog hair in his pubes but that doesn't mean anything.
No,
it does it,
it's circumstantial.
Um,
maybe that's what it is.
So whatever.
So I didn't get upset by that guy.
I mean,
my,
how my life went was in my twenties,
my early twenties.
I was like this fucking like really quiet,
got along with everybody.
And then all of a sudden out of nowhere,
like my anger would flare up like that fake volcano in front of that fucking
casino out there in the desert.
What does it treasure island.
Right?
Um,
and then people would be like,
what the fuck is that?
Is they look for their eyebrows.
Okay.
And uh,
then I didn't know how to apologize.
And that would be the end of the relationship
and
late twenties.
So when it came to the surface thirties brutal came out of the 30s.
Right before I hit the ground at,
I started to pull it up a little bit.
Now I'm somewhere in the middle.
I'm a fucking mess.
Everybody.
I really am.
I don't know why you're listening to this other than maybe it makes you feel
better about yourself.
I don't fucking know.
Or maybe you just hate your job.
Do you guys watch any football yesterday?
Great.
Gabe.
Some great games and some not so great games.
I'll tell you,
if you guys taped the Patriots Bengals game,
if you are a fan of ugly,
ugly,
ugly turn away from the TV,
football,
that was an ugly one.
And um,
and I dunno,
I dunno,
this is going to be a,
I have to watch the rest of the game because I was so fucking exhausted.
I only get two hours sleep.
So I watched,
I watched right up until the third quarter when it out went off the rails.
So I still have to watch the rest of the game when it starts raining and all
that type of shit.
But uh,
it was just,
neither team could score a fucking point.
Bunch of God damn field goals.
Um,
and the Patriots lost.
But I would have,
what are you going to do?
I mean,
I thought at this point we'd be fucking two and three foreign one.
I'll take it.
But uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno what to take about anybody at this point.
You're looking at the God damn cowboys Broncos game and all you fucking big
buckled.
Big stupid hat.
Fucking facelift.
Botoxed overly made up cons in Dallas.
If you fucking jump on Tony Romo after that game you are at,
you're a fucking moron.
How many points does the guy have to score to win a God damn game?
Fucking put up 48 points against the Broncos.
48 fucking points and then the end,
he throws an interception goods.
Same Old Toady.
All right.
It's the same.
I'll told you right there.
I swear to God,
he's like a ranch hand.
I used to have,
he could play find shit.
Eight Brian,
800 cattle into fucking row and then he dropped it on his foot.
Wouldn't get that last one.
Yeah.
Well you,
you'll get their last one or what the fuck you do the whole her for.
I ain't going to do the whole fucking hard.
I fucking do it myself there.
That,
maybe
not with that fucking accent.
Listen man,
the guy scored 48 fucking points in his goddamn defense.
Put them in a situation where now he had to go out and score better than 51 just
to get a goddamn victory.
So yeah,
you got a sling it
and that dude who picked it off with was laid out.
It was an incredible interception.
Alright,
so,
hey,
I'm fucking stick on with Tony over here.
Um,
and then you got the Broncos who,
uh,
that they're doing that Miami Dolphins,
Dan Marino thing right now with this did just outscoring people.
They're letting up a lot of fucking points.
They're letting up a lot of points.
And I'll tell you as a fan of NFL football when I've seen in the past is,
um,
if you score a zillion points during the regular season and you let up half a
zillion points,
uh,
you lose in the playoffs.
Playoffs because you end up running into fucking amazing defenses that win games
20 to 17 when you run into that fucking team.
All right?
And they slow the whole fucking thing down,
you know,
slow down the other offense in that type of shit.
Then you'd done if they have any sort of running game and then they keep your
fucking guy off the field,
all of a sudden you're sitting there with your pockets turned inside out going,
where's my proverbial football wallet there?
Jesus,
Bill,
she's got diarrhea porn out of your mouth this week.
Don't you talk in all kinds of shit?
Yeah.
So I don't even know.
I don't know.
I don't even know where the Broncos,
I don't know who shot.
I don't.
Who's not?
Um,
then you have Seattle.
We,
right.
They fucking go in and um,
they got beat by the goddamn colts
in last week if fucking that dude from the Texans who,
uh,
according to Paul Versey,
it was talking to him this morning.
He's thrown a pick six,
four weeks in a row,
but he doesn't throw a pick six.
That's two games they lost on the road.
And that's a knock against that team.
They're saying that they're not good on the road.
Jesus Christ.
This is shaping up to be a very interesting football season.
And you know why that is?
Because they have a hard cap.
So everybody's in it.
You hear that baseball and be a basketball.
I haven't even watched baseball.
I don't even know if it's working or not.
Um,
anyway,
so there he go.
So there's my sports talk for the week.
Hey,
anybody out there left?
Any ladies left?
I went on the road this week with a Joe Barden,
Nick Roosevelt Tailgate Legend,
the godfather of our fucking tail gate.
If anybody's getting his ring kissed on that wonderful fucking New Year's day,
it's Joey be,
I got to tell you something.
That fucking guy made me laugh.
I just keep,
that guy kills me.
If you get a chance to see Joe Partic do stand up,
um,
I don't know how to describe it.
It's just watching a crowd figure out who the fuck he is.
It takes him,
I swear it takes them about two and a half,
three minutes,
and then they're onboard and they're going on the ride.
And,
uh,
I don't,
I don't know how to tell you what the fuck he was.
He,
he went,
we will walk in through Seattle and he started talking about homeless people.
He had me fucking die and laugh.
And I'm like,
you've got to do that tonight.
And he tried it out when we were at the,
uh,
the beautiful pageant theater in a,
in Seattle.
And by the way,
we both walking around talking about how much we loved that fucking city,
man,
that is an underrated Seattle,
Washington,
especially if it's,
if it's sunny up.
Thank you for that shit you took last night.
Um,
the fuck am I talking about?
You know,
what's crazy about the Seattle?
Every time I fly in,
first of all,
usually it's raining and I'm freaking out that we're going to crash.
But this time it was sunny and,
uh,
we were flying out over whatever the Puget sound,
whatever the hell it is.
And I had the window seat and I looked down and,
you know,
I've been meaning to find this fucking house.
You have a goal and you land,
you'll,
you coming in for a landing and you're looking down over these neighborhoods and
it just looks like,
you know,
you know the little houses all made out of ticky tack that Bullshit.
And then every once in a while you fly over one of those Illuminati
neighborhoods and it could even be your home state.
And it just so,
because the winds are different,
they just flew over a different area that day and you look down like you're
going to,
where the fuck are those houses?
Is that a school or is that a house?
Well,
what is that?
W W it was one of those deals we were coming in,
I feel like a different way than usual.
And I had the window seat and I looked out and what I saw,
it can't be described as a mansion,
whatever.
What's the next size up from a mansion?
Like a villa?
Is that the word you use?
You know what it looked like.
You guys ever see that movie?
The dirty dozen with Lee Marvin and Charles Bronson.
Do you remember when all those Nazi officers were in that,
that they were in France and they were in that day,
you know,
cause they were occupying France and they took over the whole fucking country.
And so they were in that giant looking like castle type thing that all these
rooms and these,
that's what this thing looked like.
And um,
we're flying over the thing and it was surrounded by these beautiful tall trees
all around the house.
And then on three sides of it,
it looked like three manicured fairways in the shape of like football fields.
Absolutely fucking immaculate.
And it was right on this like peninsula and there was water around it.
And then you had to walk like a hundred yard yet walk like fucking look.
It looked like 200 feet of woods from the house and then a hundred yard football
field.
And then right on the edge of the water was one of the coolest looking in ground
pools I've ever seen in my life.
Like you,
you'd have to take a fucking tram from the house to get to the pool.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
I'm going to try and find it.
I don't know how to tweet it or something like that.
I don't want to tweet somebody fucking house,
but,
uh,
I don't know who lives there,
but if there is people that meet every day to decide whether it rains or not,
that guy who lives there or that lady there at that meeting,
casting their vote.
Cause I dunno,
I've never seen a fucking house like that on my life.
Um,
so anyways,
so we go into Seattle and as usual,
and this is the last time I'm doing it,
I went down to that stupid fucking fisherman's wharf there where they throw,
show him throwing the fish.
And as I was walking there,
this is the first time I walked in there,
I was like,
why am I going down here?
This is such a touristy thing to do.
You know,
the food's going to suck and it's going to be overpriced.
And that's exactly what the fuck happened.
You know,
I,
I got like some Crab Burger,
Bart.
Nick got his,
his burger,
his burger was cold.
Mine was all right.
And I'm like,
of course nobody from Seattle goes down here to see a bunch of asshole tourists
by in Seattle,
magnets and sweatshirts with the fuck did they go and I forgot to ask.
I Dunno.
So anyways,
so I had a shit sandwich with a side of fries there.
So,
uh,
then I went out,
I did the show at the paramount theater and um,
it was crazy.
Like the theater was one of these deals where like you,
um,
I don't know,
just the way it was set up,
like you said,
the joke and there was like half a second pause and then,
then you'd hear the laughter coming back to the stage.
So kind of fucked up my timing at first and everything went great.
And in the end somebody finally yelled,
Seattle and I kind of brought up the fact that I had sung,
we are the loudest or whatever.
I got booed a little bit,
but they were cool about it.
And,
um,
I dunno,
it was just,
it was an awesome show.
And then I found out that,
uh,
Dave Chappelle was in town right around the corner to me.
And Bart.
Nick,
like two little school girls literally ran over to where he was performing and
got to watch the last 10 minutes of his set,
which of course his last 10 minutes crushed.
Anything that I've ever written in my entire career.
You know,
it was a nice,
uh,
it was in that,
what do you call it and not eyeopener,
whatever,
like this,
you know,
the second you'd think like,
Hey,
I think I'm getting a handle this.
Ah,
wait a minute,
I still suck.
Okay,
cool.
Um,
so it was an awesome night and then we went to this fucking bar.
Chapelle was over at the Moore Theater,
which is the one where Eddie Vedder and Pearl Jam made that one where he was in
the dirty shorts.
Right.
And he dropped down into the crowd after he stared at him for uncomfortably long
time.
Um,
so we went to this bar right around the corner and it just seems shady.
The second we walked in and I,
according to Bart,
the bouncer said,
hey,
when we walked in,
after he checked Barton excited d,
he said,
good luck.
So I proceed to drink way more than I should have.
And you know,
the end of the night comes and I'm hungry.
So I go up to the front desk and I,
yeah,
you guys Zara's.
They're like,
no,
there's fucking drunk Leprechaun.
Here's a pizza menu.
Get away from the front desk.
You're scaring the lace.
So I vaguely remember this.
I went upstairs and I'm trying to order a pizza and something in my back of my
head goes,
you should be like,
this is a sour.
So I called him up and they were like a thank you for calling Gina's pizza.
Can you hold please?
And you know,
can you hold please?
They don't wait for a response.
They immediately put you on hold.
They show,
they should just say,
hey,
welcome to fucking Freddy's pizza.
I'm putting you on hold.
But they don't care.
Welcome to Tony's pizza.
Can you hold please?
And they put me on hold.
So I'm sitting there and I'm sitting there and I think I actually passed out for
a second and I woke up and I was still on hold or I,
I think I passed that with my eyes open.
Like one of those things,
I just started thinking about shit and I forgot what I was doing and I was just
like,
why is one of my ears hotter than the other?
Oh,
I'm on halt.
I was,
I got a fucking,
let me call back.
So I call back again.
Hey,
welcome to Geno's pizza.
Can you hold,
please put me on fucking hold again.
And as I was like,
no,
I just want to learn a bit.
And they already had me on hold.
So I sat there for another fucking couple minutes.
My ears getting hot again.
So I hang up and I don't really remember what I said,
but I called them back and as it going,
hey,
welcome to Tony's pizza.
I just start dropping f bombs going,
yell,
fuck,
I'm foot fucking Samia fucking all you fucking ass.
I just want to fucking be fucking I,
I can't remember.
I said,
fuck like 58 times.
And the guy in the other end goes,
hey buddy,
buddy,
you,
you need to relax.
And I just kept,
I was like,
it was like I was filibustering with Tourette's.
I and I plowed right through that firefighter is hung up on me and they went
over to the bed,
bright passed out,
face down,
you know,
in the pillow,
breathing in carbon dioxide for the rest of the night and woke up with a brutal,
brutal hangover as I had to fly to Phoenix the next day.
And I had one of those ridiculously smiling,
like a fucking maniac.
A stewardess is like,
I dunno what happened.
Like
she's still putting on this makeup to the point.
She looked like some crazy clown and she was just saying,
hey,
how are you?
Yay.
Yeah,
like adding syllables to fucking one syllable words day.
And it was just kinda like,
can I get it?
She would drink this morning
just fucking like,
you can see it.
Her life was almost over the hill of hope and she was just going to go,
she's just pulling back the throttle and she's going to go as positive as she
possibly can,
hoping if she puts this fucking energy out there,
something loving is going to come back to her.
It was one of the most uncomfortable fucking flights I've ever had and I was
hung over and the more I was coming at her with my negative energy,
like,
can you fucking stop smiling at me?
All right,
I just need some water.
Right to get rid of the throbbing in my head.
It made her pull back on the stick even more to the point.
I think she went into a stall.
Um,
I don't know.
It was one of those deals.
It probably,
I'm sure she was completely normal and it was just the fact that I was so God
damn drunk that uh,
or so hung over that um,
that her extra bubbly personality was coming across that way.
I don't know.
As always,
as always,
I was probably in the wrong,
but I'm too immature to admit it.
So with that,
that's the beginning of the podcast bill way.
You are listening to the Monday morning podcast.
If you just happened to walk by somebody's earbuds,
um,
I do one of these every single week and if you probably sitting there going,
hey,
how do I support this podcast?
How can I have help out this freckled content?
How can I do it?
This real cunt?
How can I not say fuck him and everything that he does?
Uh,
well,
this is what you can do.
You can go to the podcast page.
You can click on the a pod.
Yeah,
you go to [inaudible] dot com you click on the podcast page and over on the
right,
there's a banner for amazon.com and if you are thinking of buying anything,
if you just go to Amazon through my site,
you click on it,
you go to Amazon,
everything's still costs the same.
And I get credit for driving traffic to their site.
They give me a little skim off the top.
I take the skin,
put it in my pocket,
take a little bit of a skim out,
give it to the wounded warriors project.
So you helping me and you're helping the troops and you're helping America.
Um,
or you can always also download one of my specialists if you'd like or buy the
hard copy DVD version of it off of the merge page.
That's a wonderful thing to do.
It's a,
makes a great gift.
Makes a great gift.
Christmas coming up for someone you really don't give a shit about.
You just want to spend 20 bucks.
There you go.
You're fuck.
Um,
laugh it up.
Conti.
I'll see you next Christmas.
All right.
And it makes a great gift I think at this point.
Uh,
for a hipster,
cause I know that they've moved onto cassette tapes.
There's somewhere in like cassette tapes right now.
So eventually DVDs are going to be cool again cause it's not a blu ray and um,
you can sell it to them
in a couple of years and then they can go off on their fucking bicycle.
It's 10 feet in the fucking air for no,
no apparent reason.
All right,
a dollar slate,
shit,
slave dollar shave club,
everybody,
this is blowing up.
Everybody's loving this.
Even the ladies,
I think they are loving it when they shaved their legs and their private punch,
the dollar shave club,
there are so many things in the world that irritate me.
Things like you get your motorcycle license and everybody goes,
it's not a matter of if it's a matter of when,
but it's you by his scooter.
Nobody says that to you.
They just call you a pussy,
you know?
Or if you're riding down the street and F or on a bicycle like that is even more
dangerous than a motorcycle riding out in traffic,
listening to reo Speedwagon so he can't even hear the traffic around you.
Anyways,
there's a lot of things that you were taking me overly positive stewards is when
I have a hangover.
When there are so many things that can irritate you,
why would you want to add raises to the list?
That doesn't make any sense.
What do you say and bill,
I'm telling you through dollar shave club,
it's time to stop milking your razor blade.
I know with brand name razors that you're used to paying outrageous prices and
exhausting those razors until they start to look like a rusty soda can.
Well,
guess what?
It's time to move on.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing quality blades to your door for just a few
bucks a month.
They're cheap and they're sending them right to you.
You can be in your damn underwear.
Walk up to the door,
freak out the f,
the Fedex guy over the hell they send them,
and you've got a nice smooth shave within 10 minutes of that depending on your
abilities for opening packages.
Anyways,
let me,
let me carry on here.
Never think about it again.
They send you a pack every month so you can change your blades every week.
I love these guys and your face is going to love him too.
They got a new one.
They gave a new product called a one wipe Charlie.
It's a buttwipe for men and it's classy.
Check out the video for that and sign up for your razors today.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash burr.
That's dollar shave club.com forward slash PIR or go to [inaudible] dot com and
click on the dollar shave club banner.
Alright,
Hulu plus everyone.
You've probably tried hulu.com if you're even remotely informed,
if you're in the loop,
if you're one of the cool kids,
you've probably tried hulu.com well,
guess what?
Now it's time to try Hulu.
Plus you can watch your favorite shows anytime,
anywhere.
Hulu plus plus lets you watch thousands of hit TV shows and a selection of a
claimed movies on your television or on the go with your smartphone or tablet
and it all streams in HD for the best viewing experience possible with Hulu.
Plus.
You can watch your favorite current TV shows like Saturday night live community,
family guy,
maybe breaking bad.
You can also check out exclusive content including Hulu originals like the
awesomes starring Snl,
Seth Meyers and Moon Boys' starring Chris O'Dowd from bridesmaids.
Hulu plus offers a great selection of a claim films for only seven 99 seven 99 a
month.
You can stream as many TV shows and movies as you want,
wherever you want right now.
You can go.
You can try Hulu plus for two weeks when you go to Hulu plus.com/bill that's a
special oftener offer for my listeners.
Make sure you use Hulu plus.com/bill so you get the extended free trial.
All right,
that's very important.
If you want the extended free trial hula plus.com/bill all right,
who will come?
hulu.com Hulu plus.com/bill come on bill.
Do that now or Click Hulu plus banner on the podcastPage@billbird.com and
lastly,
he voice everyone.
Ie voice.
All right.
You have an idea for a business you want to get out from underneath the crushing
weight of your cubicle.
If you're an entrepreneur and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're in a high rise window,
window view,
fancy pants office,
or do you want them to know that you sitting there in your underwears with he
voice,
you can create the appearance,
some entire building sales,
customer support,
tech support,
you name it.
People going to think you got it.
Why?
Because if he voice give your customers the royal treatment with he voice,
he voice will fall.
We're forward business calls to your home,
mobile device or any other number you choose.
Wherever you are,
he voice will find you.
If you don't have time to take your call,
take a call.
It's not a problem.
It will be routed to you as a voicemail and you can read it at your convenience
as an email.
However you want it.
They can send it to you.
He voice not only gives you an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge the big companies have over you right now.
And that's the biggest selling point right there.
Okay?
And now you can try he voice for free for 30 days.
Go to [inaudible] dot com or just go to the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com
and click on the voice banner.
All right,
back to the podcast.
You know,
I mentioned in that I mentioned that whole thing about motorcycles,
scooters and bicycles.
Now I look,
I know motorcycles are dangerous,
but uh,
how come?
Uh,
scooter's not dangerous.
What?
Because it's some little skinny nerd riding the fucking thing or a celebrity
chef for some lady with a little ladybug helmet on.
All of a sudden get t boned by a fucking f 100 is an a problem.
I saw a guy today was on,
on,
uh,
was riding a bicycle in Los Angeles on a major fucking street.
All right.
And he had his earbuds in listening to music and he's doing that thing where
he's riding like eight to 10 feet off of the curb and this traffic behind him
having to slow down and go around them.
It's that to me is,
is more suicidal than riding a motorcycle in La without a helmet.
I might be wrong,
but I'm just saying,
I know bill,
you just saying,
hey,
by the way,
we have some,
we have some fucking hilarious,
uh,
youtube videos that some listeners made about this podcast to fans made a
youtube video.
Um,
two different fans.
Okay.
One fan made one.
It's a collection of every low GG that I said in the past year.
Uh,
it's amazing and right as it gets annoying,
he always has it become funny again.
It probably,
it's probably going to know you guys,
but it's like the amount of work that it took to put the whole thing together.
Um,
it's fucked.
And it might be something you want to get a little high and then listen to a or
drunk or whatever and then call a pizza parlor and Kershaw your brains out at,
um,
uh,
we'll have the link for that one.
And the other is tech start of basically,
um,
text and art added to me singing a song when I sang that song.
Do you know what it means to Miss New Orleans?
They did this really cool thing that,
that once again made me laugh out loud and I don't,
I don't laugh about a lot of thanks.
You know why?
Cause I'm a sad clown.
Um,
so,
oh,
by the way,
I didn't,
the El Paso Gig finally happened.
Bump,
bump,
bump out up,
out of it.
Finally happened.
I want to thank everybody who came out to that.
Everybody came out to San Jose.
That was another great,
Oh fuck,
I forgot that story.
We,
we perform there,
just a awesome crowd.
And at the end of the night,
we stayed in a hotel.
We just had to walk a block and a half over to the venue.
So me and Bart Nica leaving,
right?
We had a couple of crowns when we were in a,
the theater there and we're walking out and,
um,
we should have went right.
We went left,
we zigged and we should have zagged and what should we just start walking and
we're just kind of feeling good cause it was a great show and we were going to
meet a couple of friends to go have something to eat and uh,
we're walking and we'll walk in and we'll walk,
we'll walk walking.
And all of a sudden we went like 10 blocks and Barneys finds like,
dude,
what the fuck is a hotel?
And I'm like,
I dunno,
it starting to rain.
And I got my fucking box of DVDs were walking down the street looking like we
both just got kicked out by our fucking wife's,
you know?
And uh,
I dunno.
Like,
I just finally googled,
where the hell are,
our hotel was on the smart phone and I realized we were like 15 blocks in the
other direction.
We will late the people who wanted to meet us for dinner with texting us.
Long Story Short,
next thing you know,
I'm on one of those.
Uh,
we took one a bicycle taxi,
right?
We took a bicycle taxi,
me and Barton Nick sitting there with a glass of crown royal each in a plastic
cup.
I got my,
I had my suitcase,
my wheelie suitcase with my DVDs in it.
He has this seed,
these,
and we're sitting there riding this guy with a green Mohawk is riding us in this
light misting rain and went drinking whiskey.
And it was fucking,
it was hilarious.
It was great.
The wind in our hair or what's left of mine and uh,
we've just sitting there laughing our ass off.
We couldn't look at each other in the back of this fucking bicycle,
Rick Shaw without cracking up because it's kind of a romantic thing to do.
And A,
I dunno,
it was just one of those things,
just laughing our ass off.
Then we went to this,
um,
is pizza a pizza,
this Italian restaurant,
a famous one where they have like career waiters.
The waiters are unbelievable and they got like wear the jackets and stuff.
And uh,
I know I've eaten there before.
I want to say it was called Joe's
and I got a chicken palm.
It was delicious.
I was fucking delicious.
So
yeah.
Did I forget any other stories over then?
The last night we worked at the celebrity celebrity theatre in Phoenix,
Arizona.
It was in the round and those are always just immediately amazing,
um,
shows and I got to send the videos that I took there,
just the amount of people that have performed there.
George Carlin taped a special,
there is second one ever in 78.
Louis C k just did one there.
Um,
Paul Mooney had worked there,
all these amazing comics and then all these bands,
Stevie Ray Vaughan and the instep tour,
miles Davis,
Liberace performed there the first time they could make the thing just the stage
turn a little bit.
Um,
cream played there,
van Halen on their first tour played there was fucking insane Tony Bennet,
all of these unbelievable names and then,
uh,
two jackasses
from the Rosebowl gates.
So it was amazing to become part of that history.
And then afterwards they have this whole lounge area with the entire staff hangs
out and drinks.
And uh,
we was sitting there back in the green room and I was like,
I said,
you know,
I had some friends that came to visit a buddy of mine from back in the day and
he married this woman from New Zealand.
Okay.
And,
uh,
they came up,
she had a 16 year old daughter from a previous relationship or marriage or
whatever.
And they came up to us and they said,
you know,
we have a tradition in New Zealand that if a performer comes to town and gives a
great show that we give them a performance back.
And their 16 year old daughter came up and started doing this thing on the
table.
I guess some people have ripped it off on youtube,
but I guess this is the original one where they start.
She just done the tune,
this whole fucking beat with this cup.
And then as she's,
it's really was syncopated and all this shit just to keep that going.
And then she started singing this song about thank you for coming to the town
and we're sorry that you're leaving.
And when she would get to the chorus of it,
her mother from across the room started singing the other harmony.
It was one of the most pure artistic things I've ever seen.
It was a paper Cup and two people singing and for half this,
I was going to start filming it with my iPhone.
And I was like,
no,
that's what's wrong with fucking everything right now.
Why can't this moment just happened?
And I can't just sit here and watch it rather than viewing it now through my
phone screen.
You know what I mean?
So,
um,
so that happened.
And then the last second I was like,
you know,
hey,
they said that,
you know,
the staff's upstairs drinking and they brought us through the catacombs of the
place and all of a sudden you walk into like this Sinatra like fucking lounge
and they're all drinking.
We all come walking in,
they're like,
hey,
next thing you know,
I'm getting shit faced again.
So needless to say,
I'm back to drinking juice,
feast of famine right now.
So I'm juicing all day today.
I'm even going to do yoga like a fucking twinkle toe over there.
And um,
I'm going to,
well,
I'm going to get my fucking self,
I'm going to get knock off the booze weight from this weekend.
So anyways,
Jesus Christ,
if I run my mouth enough,
um,
oh,
by the way,
is anybody,
uh,
anybody else kind of looking at,
it's like when the government was going to shut down,
I don't know about you guys,
but I was terrified.
Like,
is there going to be anarchy is going to be beat People's storm in my fucking
house with torches.
Like,
people hung from a,
you know,
street lights and that type of shit.
Uh,
it's amazing how part of the government shutdown.
And like,
unless you work for him,
you don't really notice
why do we need governments?
Um,
that would be amazing if they just quietly without anybody noticing,
just stopped having governments.
And if nobody knew,
everyone would just sorta like still behave themselves.
Would that work?
Well how would you pay the cops and all that?
I don't fuck it though.
I guess it wouldn't work,
but I'm amazed at how well it's working with part of the government shutdown and
actually saw some quote,
I heard this woman say on the news that the Federal Reserve
okay.
Is trying to help out with the misbehaving government.
And that was one of the fucking funniest things I ever heard.
Um,
all right.
And I'm not getting into all of that shit.
Alright.
Either know about it or you don't either agree with it or you don't.
And I'm tired of fucking arguing it.
Alright,
one man thrill.
Right everybody.
Let's get to the,
uh,
the letters for this week.
One man,
thrill ride.
Uh,
dear bill and steams monster.
I don't get that one.
Is that Frankenstein's bill,
Bill and stains monster.
Uh,
sell a Boston area native and ric flair enthusiasts.
All right,
so I love this guy already.
Um,
you have to check out this video.
A guy recorded it before returning to his Alma Mara to play the in the alumni
game.
It's absolutely,
there's nothing you,
you can come back with after this.
It's perfect.
I wish I could hear Patrice has reaction.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Oh,
I guess that was a youtube video.
What?
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking intro that was.
I have to watch this the way I have to watch it live.
Is it a campus university to relive his glory days at the 2013 Fitchburg State
Baseball University?
Oh,
I'm not baseball game.
I'm in the parking lot right now.
Hammering a bacon egg and she hold the CI and preparation to go deep with
foreheads and put on a laser show to the likes of which you have never witnessed
in your entire one.
All right,
I'm going to watch the rest of this.
I know it's going to get better.
You got to have the visual of it.
This guy,
this guy's not fucking around,
right?
I'm going to watch that.
How do you not love sports?
I get it.
I can understand why you don't love it.
You know why you don't love it?
Because you sucked at it.
But then you,
you're not good at being a superhero either.
But how do you get into that
captain America,
we totally beat the shit out of the hole because he has that little sphere with
the star on it.
Advice for young marriage.
Dear Bill,
uh,
love your stuff,
Yada,
Yada.
I'm in a pickle.
I married when I was 18 to a 30 year old woman.
Get Out.
Okay.
Get out immediately.
If you're wired like a man,
get out.
A woman is,
has more sophisticated wiring than a man,
so she can be 12 years or younger.
All right?
I Dunno if they're more sophisticated,
but different things motivate themselves themselves.
What am I seeing?
Motivate them.
All right.
They're motivated by different things other than look at the dates on her.
Um,
all right.
I don't.
All right,
so when you're 38 she's going to be 50
all right,
and you're going to walk into the bedroom.
I don't know.
That's,
that's a,
okay.
Maybe I'm not mature enough to do that.
Okay.
Why am I super imposing my shit onto your shit?
Why don't I just read what the fuck you have to say.
I'm sorry.
That was a real selfish moment there.
All right.
This guy is in a pickle.
I'm married.
He says I'm married.
I married when I was 18 to 30 year old woman whom I deeply loved.
I didn't get to that point.
I'm already telling you leave.
I'm sorry sir.
Anyways,
he goes,
I had low self esteem then I used to play world of Warcraft,
be lazy and have a beard.
I am 23 now and I still love my life,
but my life has changed.
I'm fit,
clean shaven and more successful.
Therefore,
women are showing interest in me at last.
My wife is getting older and I still liked her and a lot like her a lot and find
her attractive,
attractive.
But the age gap coupled with her bad pms is starting to affect.
Yeah.
And that's not going to get better sir.
Like,
and she's still young.
I already know where I'm going to go with this.
My wife is kind fun when not having pms and a good mother.
Oh,
you have kids?
Yeah.
Oh wait a second dude.
When I am around hot 18 to 25 year old women,
I feel like I can not control myself.
So far I have control of myself,
but I feel like I'm fighting a losing battle.
What do I do?
My wife has seen the conflict within me and sympathizes.
She sometimes says that I can have some fun with other women if I tell her
first.
But I don't know if this is true or if or is a honey trap.
Uh,
my,
I don't know what that means.
Uh,
my wife is honest,
but when emotions get in the way,
I don't know how she will behave.
Do I secretly cheap when I have a good opportunity to get away with it?
Do I talk to her about some freedom?
Do I leave her before the time bomb and implodes,
explode,
sorry.
Or do I knuckled down and masturbate myself into submission?
Having lower self esteem and missing out on fun,
but being a better husband.
Um,
oh dude.
Uh,
I applaud your honesty.
listen,
you have to do what's right for you at the end of the day.
I don't know if you add up though.
Are those kids,
your kids?
I Dunno dude.
Look,
I'm not trying to blame her,
but what kind of a 30 year old marries an 18 year old man or woman.
All right,
you're a fucking kid.
She's a woman.
She married a fucking child and I'll legally,
you're a man,
but you're not.
And that goes the same thing.
If a guy,
a fucking 30 year old man marries an 18 year old,
like I don't know how that's fucking legal.
Even though the woman is legal and she is a woman,
she's a fucking child compared to a 30 year old.
All right.
And just the,
the mental fucking tennis.
Okay.
That just how much further those are.
That's a huge amount of time in your life.
All right?
If you're 50 and your wife's 38 or you're 50,
your husband's 38,
that's a different thing.
Okay.
30 to 18 is huge.
I mean,
you talking like she's almost twice your fucking age.
12 year gap.
You've only lived 18 years.
What does she,
three quarters your age come on you mathletes what is that?
All right.
I don't know what to tell you.
If you already have kids with this woman,
I don't know what the answer is,
but if those are her kids,
um,
you're 23 so you've been married five,
she's 35.
She still has a chance.
She's still young.
She can still go out and meet somebody more around her age.
Um,
dude,
you got married too young.
You got way too fucking young to somebody.
Way Too old.
That's what I think.
That's just what I think,
but I don't have the feelings you have for this woman.
All right.
This is just me on the outside looking in.
I am a commitment foe.
I am a psycho and I am a piece of shit when it comes to fucking women.
All right?
And I've earned that in spades.
Believe me.
So take what I'm saying at a with a grain of fucking salt.
All right?
Um,
yeah,
you're talking about a 45 year old guy who never get married and fucked up every
relationship he was ever again.
That's what,
that's what you're talking to right here.
Okay.
So
I just know what I wanted to do when I was 23 years old and I was also iron man.
I mean like 18 to 23 years old.
You're supposed to be out there
experiencing being young and,
and uh,
and all that has to offer.
That's what you supposed to,
in discovering about yourself.
Okay?
Now,
however,
if you married this woman and we had kids with her,
you do have a responsibility and that's a whole other can of worms and a can of
worms that is not in my life yet.
So I don't know how to advise you on that.
Okay.
All right.
You know,
there are some things,
you know,
some things in life you do miss out on and sometimes you get this other great
thing,
but because of that great thing you,
you don't have enough time to enjoy this other thing.
So you might be in that situation.
If you have fucking kids.
I would say as somebody else who has kids,
ask somebody else who's in your boat,
but look,
if those are her kids and you got married at 18 and she's 30 and now you're 23
and she's 35.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I don't,
I don't know what to do that whole fucking,
I don't know what to do.
Uh,
I would say get out.
That's what I would say.
I guess that's what I am saying,
but I,
I don't understand whether you have kids yet.
I don't know if you have kids with her and I don't know how,
how deep is your love for that woman?
How deep is your,
I don't know.
You know,
um,
I'm,
I don't have enough information on that one,
sir,
but my gut saying that you should shove it off to buffalo.
I feel you know what?
I feel they're responsible on that one.
I don't know that I gave you good advice,
sir.
I would ask around more so there's a jump off point.
My ignorant thoughts.
All right.
Girlfriend wants me to take an STD test.
Jesus Christ.
That was coming right out of the gate,
Huh?
How far are we here?
All right,
girlfriend wants me.
You know what?
Before I do that,
let me just bang out the last couple advertising.
Quit your complaining.
I got two more here,
right?
All right,
here we go.
Legal,
zoom,
everybody.
Legal.
Zoom.
A lot of pride comes along with starting your own dream business,
but think about the stress you'll feel if you don't take the right steps to
legally protect yourself and your business,
personal assets and all that stuff.
Right from the beginning,
that's,
I recommend legal zoom.com during the past 12 years,
over a million business owners have trusted legal zoom to help start their
businesses.
Legal zooms will legal zooms.
Legal Zoom will save you a lot of time and a pile of money on startup costs.
Plus they provide solutions to help you run a successful business.
Legal Zoom can provide self health services at your specific directions or
connect you with an attorney,
but they are not a law firm.
Just go to legalzoom.com today to see what's right for you.
Form an LLC,
get a Dba,
incorporate or form a nonprofit all starting at just $99 plus.
You'll save even more when you enter burpee.
You are are in the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com promo code [inaudible] one more time.
Legal zoom.com Promo Code Burr.
Lastly,
stamps.com uh,
some small companies think leasing a Po,
leasing a postage meter is how business businesses get postage for their letters
and packages,
but they don't realize that there's a better way.
What does that way say it with me,
everybody.
stamps.com unlike a postage meter,
stands.com has no hidden fees like a meter in charger or reset fees.
No long term contracts,
no extra hardware to buy or lease.
stamps.com can save you up to 80% compared to a postage meter.
Plus with stamps.com you could do more than you can with the meter.
Using your existing address book,
send tracking information to recipients with the click of a button.
The choice is clear.
stamps.com offers more features for a fraction of the cost.
You'd have to be a moron not to try it.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs.
I never had a problem.
I'm an idiot and I can use it.
If I can do it.
You can too.
Special offer right here.
Use My last name,
Burr,
uh,
for a no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes a digital scale enough
to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
burr.
Okay,
back to the podcast.
Girlfriend lady wants me to take an STD test.
How your bill all right.
Right there.
I think you're from England.
Don't you guys say that over there?
Hi Ya.
Um,
so,
oh by the way is I said Wales,
England a year,
a year ago,
a couple of weeks back.
There's separate countries.
I never knew I could never do Scott,
Scotland.
It's own country.
You have it cause it's Great Britain,
Ireland fight needs.
It's this fucking confusing and they don't teach us that shit over there.
So Scotland,
Wales,
England,
three different countries.
There you go.
They all share,
share the same island.
And for some reason they don't go to war with one another,
although I don't think they like each other.
And from what I've heard,
England,
they're the country whales are allegedly having sex with sheep and a Scotland.
I Dunno.
They're like barrel.
They don't wear shirts and they'll beat the shit.
They'll head.
But you know,
headbutting is Australian.
I don't know.
You don't want to fuck around.
You don't have to fuck around in any of those countries according to the movies
I've watched.
Um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So bill,
I've been going out with this girl for almost five months and everything has
been great so far.
We haven't had sex yet because she's a virgin like a virgin.
Um,
the last couple of times we went out she wanted,
she wanted to,
but we were both drunk and would just fool around and go to sleep.
I'm waiting until she is ready because I honestly do care about her.
Ah,
well you're a nice fellow.
Um,
you're not putting any pressure on her taking out you fucking cock and balls.
There's lean like,
you know,
can you help me out over here?
What,
Oh,
you or what are you?
What are you here for?
If you're not going to let you know,
you don't wanna be that guy.
Uh,
but the other day she dropped a bomb on me.
she asked me to get tested for STDs before we had sex.
All right,
well that makes sense.
If you're going to get into a committed relationship,
eventually you want to remove the latex that you can get the whole experience.
You want to go on the whole ride.
You don't want to stand next to the roller coaster watching it through the loop
de loops through you.
You want to be on that fucker.
Um,
anyways,
I have had sex with seven different girls and I always used to wear a condom and
I always scrubbed my dick after scrubbing your deck after.
I don't think that that works.
Oh wait.
They tell you to do that.
Right.
I Dunno if,
if you know,
if something got in yet,
it's already and you're just cause you're washed the area where if you get bit
by a rattlesnake and then you would wash the cut.
Does the poison leave your bloodstream?
Hi,
I'm an I'm not a doctor and I'm putting out weird fucking information.
I should shut the fuck up.
Um,
anyway,
so he watches,
he watches his dick afterwards,
but not as balls.
I've been slapped it up against it.
Um,
she said that I could have,
I could have an STD that doesn't affect guys,
but it affects girls.
Uh,
she's talking about HPV.
That's what she's saying.
He goes,
I said,
that's bullshit.
And told her I don't want to talk about it anymore.
Okay.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
You are an enlightened man and now you've,
now you went into the cave men area and you know what?
I'm not judging it because we all do it.
You'll be impatient.
You weren't pressuring her.
You'll be in a Goddamn gentlemen.
Then all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
you took off the top hat and you beat her with the cane.
That Jesus' body weight.
Why?
Why'd you do that?
All right.
He goes,
I,
he goes,
I don't know what to do.
He's like,
I don't have an STD,
but there's a little fucking voice in my head saying,
well,
maybe,
uh,
should I say fuck it and do the test or not?
Thanks man.
Much appreciated.
Love you.
Love your show.
All right.
You know the deal,
sir.
Even if you wear a condom,
there's a chance that you could have something and a HPV for the most part does
not show up,
I guess in guys for what they say.
You don't really notice it.
You have it,
but you can give it to women and it causes them all kinds of problems.
Which of which I forget what it does to them because it doesn't concern me and
I'm a selfish cunt.
All right?
So this is what I would do,
sir.
Um,
I would just go out,
if you really give a shit,
go out and get tested.
And what's great about getting tested is when it comes back and he got nothing,
you can take those seven people and clear them off the board.
Like murder cases.
You know,
if you ever watch the wire,
he,
you get to erase them all off and you don't have it.
You don't have that caseload.
All right?
You can close those cases.
They're not cold cases anymore.
You understand what I'm saying?
You've only had sex with seven people according to you.
You always wore a condom and you washed your fucking Dick and your balls.
There were not your balls,
just your Dick.
All right?
So I think you've got a pretty good chance that you're all right.
And if you're only seven in,
this is a great time.
We get tested.
All right?
Cause then what's great is when it comes back and you're negative,
you know what you are,
then you're,
you're what's known as a red shirt virgin.
Okay.
You're in your sophomore year,
but you haven't taken any hits,
if you know what I mean.
All right.
So then that makes you want to be even more careful.
Yeah.
This is what,
why don't you do this?
Just say,
listen,
I got emotional because I'm afraid that even though I've been careful,
I am scared that yeah,
when you have sex with some,
but he,
even when you wear a condom you can still catch shit.
So,
uh,
tell you what,
why don't we both go down and get tested?
We'll do it together as a couple.
I apologize for acting like a caveman.
Um,
will you forgive me?
And there you go.
Then you both go out,
you get tested,
you take her out for a little fucking a creme brulee or whatever the fuck they
like to eat.
Okay.
And then you just sit there waiting.
Here comes the river.
Um,
and hope and the flop,
you,
we have fucking win the hand.
That's all I can tell you,
sir.
But you know what?
Eventually you're going to have to fucking know one way or another and you're
only seven and this is a great time before you go down that road and you've got
30 40 50 under your belt and you're just Jesus Christ thinking all this shit
that you did and you're walking into that office with flop sweat,
okay?
You don't want to do it all right?
I think it's a great thing to go out and get tested and I think your
girlfriend's 100% in the right for asking you to do it.
I feel like your behavior afterwards was immature but understandable and you
need to make things right.
All right,
go do your thing,
man up.
Okay.
Bully.
I can beat up.
All right.
Well if there's a bully you can beat up.
He's not really a bully.
He's just an asshole.
Right?
Hey,
Billy boy,
I'm 15 year old lad from Australia in is my problem.
There was a complete Dick head at my school that always picks on me,
but here's,
here's the twist.
I could smash the shit out of this prick.
I'm 182 centimeters.
That's six feet tall,
fit 15 years old,
six feet tall.
He goes 74 kilograms.
That's 160 pounds.
Few people keeping score and other day,
and he's about five,
eight and weighs about 185 pounds.
All right,
so he's got,
he's got your bike.
He's got you buy 25 pounds,
but you have the reach advantage.
This is the tale of the tape here.
I love this.
You've got a four inch reach advantage.
Unless he has those fucking Kevin Mchale arms that are almost dragging on the
ground.
All right,
you go.
I lift weights every other day and he's just fat.
Okay.
All right.
You're definitely the favorite so far he goes,
but this isn't the biggest reason why I could smash this con.
I have about 20 years of martial arts experience.
Wait a minute.
You're 15 years old.
How do you have 20 years of experience?
Oh,
he's going to break it down.
I have about 20 years of martial arts experience when you add it all up.
I have seven years in karate,
five years in movie tie.
Jesus,
dude,
you bring those fucking needs to that fat belly.
Oh my God.
Probably got shins like a fucking street pole.
Um,
Street Pole,
stop sign,
whatever the fuck I was trying to say.
Just I pictured a telephone pole and a stop sign made out of metal and I came up
with street pole.
Look at that.
I'm inventing words here.
Seven years of karate,
five years in Muay Thai,
five years of Brazilian Jujitsu.
Jesus Christ standing up,
go to the ground.
What do you want to dope?
And three years of MMA,
he constantly calls me name like gay boy and Poof.
And he slaps me in the back of the head every day.
Dude,
you can't have that.
Uh,
this has been happening for like two months now and I haven't fought back
because I'm worried about getting in trouble from teachers at my martial arts
classes.
Any advice as welcome?
Uh,
thanks for whatever.
Whatever helps you.
Uh,
whatever help you can give me,
go fuck yourself and have a good day.
All right sir.
Well,
this is the deal.
You could sear if you actually applied what,
you know,
you could seriously hurt this guy,
but you do have to defend yourself.
So is there a way that the next time he goes to slap you in the head,
you can put them in one of those fucking those holds.
We're just holding the person's thumb and they're all of a sudden on their
tiptoes going,
all right.
All right.
Is there a way to just shoot one across the bow?
That's what I'm suggesting.
I'm not saying that you fuck this kid up and then ruin your standing with,
uh,
your,
your seafoods,
your Sensei's,
your,
your pastors,
whatever the fuck you call them down to the Dojo.
Um,
yeah,
but there's no reason for you to go to school and get slapped in the back of the
head and being called names.
Okay?
So what I would do is,
uh,
oh,
what the fuck he asking me?
This is what you do.
Jesus Christ.
Here's your solution.
Talk to one of you,
your karate masters there,
and just say,
listen,
this is the deal.
I know after everything that you've taught me that I could use what?
Mop the floor with this fet tub of shit.
But I don't want to get,
you know,
bad standing with you.
What do I do here?
Have them have them tell you what to do.
Cause they'll,
they could probably suggest they know the name of whatever that fucking
how to choke out somebody's thumb.
Whatever that thing is that you guys do that I wish I knew how to do.
Um,
okay,
but here's the deal.
One way or the another.
Uh,
there has to be a solution with this guy slap and you this slapping you in the
back of the fucking head.
Um,
okay.
Do you do,
do you know how to do a death grip yet?
Have they taught you that?
Is that an actual thing?
Why don't you do a double death grip to his man tits and twist them before he
has a chance to slap you when they had,
don't listen to anything that I'm going to suggest here.
Uh,
why don't you take some Twinkies?
Okay,
well what,
what could you do with the twinkie and a martial art thing?
Why don't you make some nunchuck Twinkies instead of slapping them in the face
with the,
with a piece of wood,
it's a,
it's a twinkie and it goes across his face.
He's humiliated.
Plus,
you know,
he's a fatty,
so he's going to have to lick it off his face and he'll get into that sugar rush
and his eyes will roll in the back of his head.
And by the time his eyes come back down,
you're going to be across the Roman.
He can't slap you in the head out of,
there's gotta be something.
Okay.
There's gotta be something to do.
Uh,
I mean at this point,
if you don't want to go physical,
I would just go verbal.
I,
you know,
he's calling you gay boy and poof on me.
Why don't you just talk about his fat tissue?
Okay.
Just at just be,
yes.
Used to be really sincere.
Just be like,
just out of curiosity,
how much do you tits way,
you know,
do you wear a sports bra or are you going to kind of go with the,
uh,
the giant pocket tee
and the fact that you're already this fat and our young age,
like how fat do you think you're going to be when you're 40?
And these are just questions,
sir.
You know,
and then when he charges you like a rhino just step out of the way and he won't
be able to slow down and maybe go flying into some desks.
I don't know sir.
But can you please tell me how this,
I,
I w I would go,
I would go to your,
uh,
your Dojo masters there,
whatever,
and I'd ask them what to do,
but there's no fucking way on any level that you should have to tolerate that.
Uh,
yeah,
I would do that.
Ah,
Jesus.
Are they going to go even really more mature?
Well,
I think you should talk to your teachers about it and then you become the
fucking guy ratted out.
You know?
I just like that it's a selection that's like this uh,
solutions they come up to on like the view.
Yeah.
You just turn around and you just face stop doing that.
I,
I'm not going to tolerate this.
You know,
I'll give you like a rape whistle or something.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know sir.
But please let me know how that works out because it's bothering me that,
that is doing that to you.
All right.
I don't like bullies.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Do
you know what I really want to tell you to do and I'm not going to,
all right.
Divorce settlement,
a divorce settlement sheet.
Uh,
dimmers,
tuber.
I claim a suburb because I don't know you personally.
Please tell me if I'm a piece of shit for doing what I thought was right.
I will give you a quick summary.
Fell in love with high school sweetheart.
Oh,
that's tremendous.
Gotten married.
Good for you.
Rented a house.
Awesome.
10 year relationship.
Wonderful.
Two years of marriage.
Cool.
No kids.
All right.
Came home to our town after a weekend with my friends in Austin to change locks
to our house.
Knocked on the door for an hour.
Cops called on me.
Cops say the woman in the house says we are separated but married and I had been
bothering her by visiting her.
Her rented house too much.
Oh my God.
Okay.
When she opened the door,
a guy in his boxers and socks came walking down the stairs.
As the door was opened,
I didn't see this coming.
Oh my God.
I own a couple of pawn shops.
My Dad left me.
My Dad left me with one and then I grew it into multiple locations.
I knew the relationship was over,
but we weren't divorced yet and I didn't want her taking half of my shit,
so I sold my company locations to my parents for $1 for tax reasons.
Ah,
that sounds like a good move.
I then bought back the company for full money in my personal account.
We've always had separate accounts.
Then I sold the company locations back to my parents for a dollar.
I think somehow I think somehow got demoted from the new owners.
Okay.
Oh,
you left out a word.
I think I somehow got demoted from the new owners from owner area supervisor to
pawnbroker,
which doesn't make much money at all.
This took me about three months to arrange.
That doesn't make sense,
dude.
Then I sold the company locations back to my parents for a dollar.
She sold it for a dollar.
You bought it back and then you sold it again and he bought it back with your
own money.
I need,
I need to be a lawyer to understand this and he goes,
I think I somehow got demoted from the new owners from owner area supervisor to
pawn broker,
which doesn't make much money at all.
This took me about three months to arrange all this,
so I acted like I was trying to work it out.
Okay.
So that she wouldn't want to divorce yet.
Needless to say,
after it was all said and done,
she thought that she was going to get a hefty amount of money
when I actually think it was a pretty fair split.
Do you think?
I did.
What I did was fucked up.
Also,
I kind of found a way around the divorce settlement,
which is an old thing you brought up.
But still I'd like your opinion.
Um,
okay.
A loyal fan who says fuck those cons,
who follow you for 15 years and give up on you.
Oh,
thank you.
Um,
no,
I think what you did was genius,
you know,
um,
the way that she went about getting this divorce and calling the cops on you and
then that's on your record that,
I mean that was,
she,
she kind of established the playing field,
you know what I mean?
It's one of those knife to a gunfight thinks she established the playing field
and um,
and you played the game accordingly.
I mean,
I think the fact that you guys both,
it seems like he got married young.
Maybe she just didn't know how to break up with you in a more of a mature way.
So she kind of broke up with you mentally stayed with you,
began another relationship,
and then just when you went away,
just drop the hammer and tried to do a one like a one stop thing.
Locks are gone.
He's bugging me.
This is the guy in fucking Sia and you,
you get all that information in 90 seconds,
um,
whatever.
So then you make sure she doesn't get the pawn shops.
I don't know.
I think that's pretty fair.
And it sounds like she's young enough to build up her own empire and with the
cold calculated way that she dealt with cutting you out of her life.
I think she's going to do great in the corporate world,
so she'll be fine.
So fuck it.
You did the right thing.
Good for you.
All right,
wrap up for the show here.
All right.
That's it.
That's it for the podcast,
by the way.
Um,
I want to thank everybody who's been listening.
The listenership has been steadily climbing up and um,
and everybody who's been coming out to my shows,
um,
I gotta tell you I'm having more fun than I've ever had on stage in my life and
I really feel like I'm going through this growth period.
I've been pushing myself this,
these things.
I've just,
a few things I've been trying to work on in my act and uh,
it's like the spending like a three year process and I feel like I'm pushing
through right now and uh,
so I just,
I dunno,
I feed off the crowd so when you guys show up,
it's really been helping to push me.
So I just wanted to say it's actually something nice for once on the podcast,
so thank you.
Um,
and I'm off the road here.
After six weeks in a row on the road,
I'm off for the next two,
three weeks.
So I'm going to be going around La trying to work on some stuff.
Re a recharge my batteries here,
juice,
do some yoga,
do some pullups,
climb the rope.
Uh,
whatever the fuck I'm going to do.
Watch some football and watch some hockey and that type of shit.
I'm going to chill out here for a few weeks and uh,
anyways,
that's the podcast for this week.
My next show's coming up,
believe it or not or not until November.
All right.
And uh,
I got to run a show's coming up for uh,
um,
doing DC,
New York City,
Philadelphia.
I don't have the exact dates.
These are all on my website.
And then I also am going to be doing,
I'm making up the last bit of the red state tour dates.
Uh,
I'm doing deadwood,
South Dakota,
Tulsa,
Oklahoma and a Wichita,
Kansas and a,
that's going to be the last of it.
So I make those up.
Is there anything else I'm doing there?
I don't know.
All I know is I'm thinking of going to deadwood a day early.
In fact,
I know I'm going to go cause I want to see some stuff when I'm out there and a,
and then I'm going to leave early the next day before Oklahoma.
Cause other,
the sooners have a game that day.
I'm going to try to make it,
unless the flex schedule makes it an eight o'clock game.
And,
uh,
and I don't know what the fuck I'm going to do in Kansas other than I'm not
going to say,
hey,
we're not in Kansas anymore,
and look around and have everybody fucking roll their eyes like they haven't
seen that 58,
I mean,
heard it 58 times a fucking day from tourists.
All right,
I'm babbling here.
That's the end of the show.
Uh,
now that the show's over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu.
Plus,
once again,
Hulu plus lets you binge on thousands of fit TV shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC,
smartphone,
or tablet.
You never have to miss a show again with your busy schedule.
It's the perfect way to consume television these days,
or movies,
whatever you want to do.
Support this podcast and get an extended free trial of Hulu plus when you go to
the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on the Hulu plus banner or go
to Hulu plus.com/bill,
that's Hulu plus.com/bill.
Uh,
that's a podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
Um,
I will see you guys in DC,
New York and Philly in a month and a,
I'm a home for the whole month.
I'm psyched going to make another fucking pumpkin pie and shit.
Get ready for Halloween.
All right,
that's it.
I'll talk to ya later.